this story just breaks my heart but
there's a happy ending paul rudd is
giving back to a young fan named brother
learning that he was being bullied at
school and his classmates refused to
sign his yearbook what's wrong with
y'all yeah seriously but brody has an
avenger on his team after learning of
his story paul sent him a signed ant-man
helmet along with a personal letter that
read in part
it's important to remember that even
when life is tough that things get
better there are so many people that
love you and think you're the coolest
kid there is me being one of them i
can't wait to see all the amazing things
you're going to accomplish
i love fun yes thank you that's so sweet
paul okay and the pair even had a very
special conversation on facetime take a
look oh touched my heart we'll see you
guys tomorrow bye
i heard about you
and i'm like i gotta talk to this kid
because this this kid sounds like my
kind of guy
[Music]
likes chess like fencing
like dinosaurs
am i right
these right here all right
well i'm very excited that uh
i get to talk to you and i get to meet
you in colorado
[Music]